some Americans may be thinking that
voting for Joe Biden in November will be
a vote against Trump but maybe it's time
to look at things a different way namely
if you vote for Biden what exactly will
you be voting for how will America
change first thing you have to realize
is that anything Biden says about being
tough on China about pushing
made-in-america stuff is a total lie
Biden has spent nearly half a century in
politics including eight years as vice
president to show us that he was an
economic populist suddenly I don't think
so
well this latter day attempt to rebrand
himself as some sort of liberal Pat
Buchanan on trade manufacturing is a
complete and utter farce instead of
America first Biden's policies have
always put American workers last and
after Biden's speech yesterday the day
before come on you might have been
wondering what have you heard all that
before the federal government spends
taxpayers money we should use it to buy
American products and support American
jobs
we'll always live by two simple rules by
American and higher American well Trump
of course sees right through what
Biden's trying to do he plagiarized from
me but he can never pull it up he likes
plagiarizing no of course a little
little joke about Biden's problem with
that Neil kenick speech all those years
ago
Biden's progressive cheerleaders they
know that Trump's full-throated embrace
of economic nationalism it's one of his
strongest appeals thus they've tried to
co-opt the message he's being very
intentional about who's been left out of
this economy we are really encouraging
everybody and giving them opportunities
to participate in this economy it will
be transformative transformative any
cursory look at Biden's long record
demonstrates he's a staunch unrepentant
globalist on trade on immigration and of
course on Foreign Affairs he's been on
the opposite side of Trump on every
major policy battle a President Biden
will install globalists and key
positions in the State Department and
the Pentagon taking us back to the Obama
days of constantly apologizing to the
world for our past sins and giving China
and Europe basically whatever they want
remember back in 2011 Biden was actually
rooting on China there's a debate here
in the United States and quite frankly
throughout most of the West is whether a
rising China was in the interest of the
United States in the wider world as a
young member of the Foreign Relations
Committee I wrote and I said and I
believe then what I believe now that a
rising China is a positive positive
development not only for China but for
America and the world writ large just
just that line alone should completely
disqualify him from the presidency how
does that work out for Hong Kong Joe
could have been more wrong on more
issues and do not think for a second
that things are gonna calm down and the
domestic front if Biden is elected the
left will be
emboldened not chastened by a Biden win
retribution will be a dividend for the
squad in the Biden era and it's just
gonna get worse they don't want you to
worry about canceled culture in fact AOC
says check your priveledge tweeting the
term cancel culture comes from
entitlement odds are you're not actually
cancelled
you're just being challenged held
accountable or unliked well tell that to
those who lost their livelihoods we're
gonna talk to a man who's being subject
to the cancel culture in just a few
moments anything it's all bad now just
wait until a Biden administration if
anyone including any company does
something the left doesn't like they'll
come under DOJ scrutiny and the Bill of
Rights is not gonna do much good for you
after all that was written by a bunch of
old dead white slaveholders moments like
the Tea Party will be treated I don't
know like moments for domestic
terrorists black lives matter they'll be
treated like heroes religious people at
least the ones that don't go along with
the radical left will be investigated
for hate crimes heck Biden already
threatened to rescind the Obama care
exemption for groups like Little Sisters
of the Poor after that Supreme Court
decision the other day and oh
homeschoolers forget it you're gonna
fake it face such strict controls you'll
just go back to public school college
and high school sports teams they're
gonna be in trouble and media companies
they'll face pressure by the FCC and
other regulatory bodies and if you take
the by the administration to court
because you want to challenge any of
this stuff well you're gonna find find
that it has at least five justices in
Washington to act as its rubber stamp
meanwhile laws that are on the books
that they don't like will become
meaningless no more enforcement of the
immigration or drug laws bienvenidos
I told us of course crime will rise as
cops are taken off the streets and
replaced with left wing social workers
and therapists Biden has already moved
away and way way way to the left on that
issue the last thing you need is an
up-armored hmmwv coming into a
neighborhood just like the military
invading they don't know anybody to
become the enemy and we agree that we
can redirect some of the funding
yes absolutely Wow
and good luck complaining about any of
this to the press after all they've
nothing more at this point that the
propaganda arm of the DNC if Biden
actually wins they'll work even harder
to protect him there is no scenario
where Donald Trump even competes with
Joe Biden who trips epithet we were
talking about this again recently on TV
with a different speech and you point
out you know just the the empathy the
the Biden empathy we really heard from
him he was trying to say to people look
I see you I'm feeling your pain but wait
I know what you're saying how could the
wealthy actually support Biden if it's a
vergence virtual certainty that crime
will skyrocket taxes will go well come
on the rich are always gonna figure a
way to you know squirrel away their
money and they're always gonna figure
out a way to be shielded by private
security and their gated communities
that's why that's the way it works in
countries like Mexico and in Guatemala
and that's where we're headed under
Biden for a long time many of you have
been very happy that you don't have to
live in left-wing cities like Baltimore
in New York or San Francisco but in just
a few months you may find out exactly
what it's like
finally let's not forget that a vote for
Biden is a vote to erase our history our
national memory and our traditions which
brings us to the riots most people on
the right they're frustrated about the
ongoing destruction but for now it's
mostly contained in areas where the
rioters feel safe the mayors of Chicago
and st. Louis are never going to arrest
and prosecute these thugs yet that's
only true so long as Republicans hold
the White House if the left gets
controlled the DOJ the writers are going
to feel safe from prosecution almost
anywhere in fact they'll know that
anyone who interferes with them will
risk federal investigation
Biden won't have to order people to do
much of anything like what blow up the
Mount Rushmore no he's not gonna do that
he just won't do anything to stop or
punish the folks who try to
as Nancy Pelosi says I don't care that
much about statues or the City Council
not a mob in the middle of the night
throwing it into the harbor will do what
they do being a citizen is a duty and
duties aren't always easy or fun to
carry out well these days when there's
so much hatred toward our country in the
media I know it's really tempting to
tune it all out and say I'm not looking
at it hide our heads under the covers
and wait for the storm to pass but this
isn't a storm and it's not going to pass
it's a vicious and well-funded movement
to take away your power and your money
and give them to people who want to
crush you
but patriotic Americans are starting to
resist this unconstitutional series of
edicts and actions of their mayors and
their governors and young and old alike
must respectfully refuse to submit to
this new normal that keeps us out of
work out of churches and out of schools
we have to teach the Democratic Party
once and for all that attacking us and
aligning with the radical social of
socialist fringe is gonna cost them
dearly
and we can absolutely do this we've
beaten the left many times before and we
can do so again in November a vote for
Trump is a vote to preserve the thing
that makes America the best country on
Earth our freedom and that's the angle